red states led the way in reopening
schools businesses keeping the
vulnerable residents safe and secure and
it's why many americans are voting with
their feet they're moving to states like
florida texas utah and others
well here for a reaction is author of
everything reminds me of something
happens to be one of my personal
favorites i'm uh so glad to have
comedian adam carolla joining us uh adam
thanks for joining us tonight on hannity
uh
you live with with gavin newsom so
what's your take on all this
well i live under gavin newsom's thumb
if i lived with him i would have killed
myself years ago
number one number two
let's just really distill this down all
right there's a travel ban against
montana because montana is evil because
of their stances on lgbt whatever
they're probably not handing out free
sexual assignment reassignment surgery
to all inmates or something insane but
either way let's just break it down
montana is an evil place because of the
way they treat the gay and lesbian
community fine then who cares who's
paying for your travel gavin gavin why
would you go to an evil place why are
you trying to beat evil on a techno on a
technicality you're the one who said it
these are this is a bad place this is
bad policy so don't go fly fishing then
don't go there i mean it's the same with
the french laundry it was the same with
the sofi stadium where he's taking
pictures with magic johnson with his
mask in his hand he doesn't believe it
he's a carpetbagger he's full of crap he
doesn't believe anything he's saying he
doesn't believe kovitz dangerous or he
wouldn't be out with 31 of his closest
friends drinking 40 grand worth of wine
and he wouldn't be standing around sofie
stadium with no mask on if he believed
it he doesn't believe it he doesn't
believe montana he doesn't believe
anything he says and i don't believe
anything he says either
you know i get the sense he wakes up in
the morning and he walks into the
bathroom and he looks in the mirror and
he says hello mr president that's the
one that's the sense i got and now he's
running ads in florida what the heck
if you saw those ads he's talking about
freedom
that was the theme of that ad patriotic
music playing talking about the fourth
in freedom
he's talking about ron desantis taking
away freedoms this is a guy who shut
down schools shut down beaches shut down
outdoor dining made sure that
two-year-olds were massed up shut down
playgrounds and hiking trails shut down
small businesses this guy's got the gall
to talk about freedom in a state that
he's locked down and by the way
we're still living under the emergency
order he's still in charge because he's
keeping the covet emergency orders going
in perpetuity so he can remain king of
california
well and i guess that's the point look i
was i'm originally from california but i
was smart enough to get out of
california why is anybody living there i
mean they can't even get people to bring
their u-hauls back to california so
people can start leaving fast enough and
he thinks he's doing it better than ron
desantis in florida come on
and basically
do the math everyone is leaving
california and going to florida no one
is leaving florida and going to
california so gavin newsom is like the
owner of an italian food restaurant
who's watching everyone walk out of his
restaurant go across the street and go
to the italian foods place across the
street and then he's standing out on the
sidewalk talking about how bad the food
is at the place across the street
well
people are voting with their feet
yeah no they they really are and um i i
think it's absurd that he's trying to
put himself in this place and take the
idea in the mantle of freedom where we
still believe things are free
adam kerala thanks so much for joining
us on hannity it's really fun for me to
talk to you i really do appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else